when I look back to the 90s and remember
Power Rangers I think of bulk and skull
slipping over banana skins a screaming
drag queen on the moon and teenagers
finding their moral fiber over
milkshakes but how dare i forget the
badass power rangers themselves and
their giant kaiju fighting robot swords
I'm Simon and this is your nostalgic
news update the Power Rangers are back
the iconic team of costume teenage
heroes will be returning to cinemas in
2017 and their new look has now been
revealed in the picture by Entertainment
Weekly if you ask me they look more like
they should be kicking the crap out of
the Covenant in the Halo franchise the
new Power Rangers movie is set for a
march twenty four twenty seventeen
release in February it was announced
that hunger games star elizabeth banks
would star is reads a repulsor the evil
sorceress intent on invading earth last
month we got our first official image of
the space diva shared on Twitter by
people speaking to e w production
designer andrew menzies explain the
approach he had taken to updating the
colorful spandex of the classic TV show
it's tricky finding a new language for a
superhero costume ours is an alien
costume that grows on them that's not
man-made you can't win everyone over but
we are trying to appeal to a more mature
audience and gain new fans the Power
Rangers first appeared on screens in
1993's Mighty Morphin Power Rangers the
show mix new American scenes with
footage taken from the Japanese show
Super Sentai to date there have been 23
TV series to earlier movies plus a
number of video games are you excited to
see the Rangers reboot maybe this time
round I'll be able to complete my power
rangers panini sticker album let me know
what you think in the comments will come
find me on twitter i'm at the Jagan or
thanks for watching and for your
entertainment news keep it gamespot
you